hi everyone welcome to our daily live
stream this is why we've almost we've
been doing this for a little bit over
two weeks for those of you all who are
new to this the whole point of this is
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and over
the last many years we've been building
resources that start in pre-k with Khan
Academy kids through elementary middle
high school and the core of college not
just math not just videos but deep
interactive exercises dashboards for
teachers English and language arts
history sciences SAT preparation and
that has made us very well-suited to
help to really step up for the the
country in the world as we go through
these school closures but we realized we
need to do as much as possible on top of
that and so the whole point of this
livestream is for all of y'all who are
using Khan Academy or thinking about
using Khan Academy or just trying to
navigate the school closures generally
we wanted a place for folks to connect
and feel connected especially in this
time of social distancing and so every
day it's very informal myself and I want
to bring some team members on we
sometimes have special guests we try to
answer your questions and make any
announcements that are relevant I do
want to start off with reminding
everyone we are not-for-profit we are
funded by philanthropic support from
folks like yourself
we were running at a deficit even before
this crisis and with this crisis our
server load is up is roughly 250 percent
of what it normally is our registrations
are 6x from teachers and parents of what
it normally is parent registrations are
20x so if any of you find yourself in a
position that you can donate please
think about doing so I want to give a
special shout out to several
corporations who've stepped up in the
last few weeks with very short notice to
help us although we need more help Bank
from America was the first followed by
18t google.org and Novartis but we need
more help from individuals and
corporations where we are literally
going to go million
a few weeks and months but with that
said I would love to I'll bring my
colleague Dan on who helps me answer all
of the questions that we get on the live
stream and I encourage all of y'all to
start asking questions on whatever
you're using YouTube Facebook whatever
channel and let's see there seems like
there's already a couple questions but
Dan you can always jump in but this
question from YouTube this is crazy
cookie 3908 it's pretty impressive that
there were probably 3907 cream cookies
before you so it says hey Sal
will there be summer classes will this
be year all year round that's actually a
super powerful question crazy cookie
3908 the you know I think about two
weeks ago the school closures were
announced in this country and really
through the world there's 15 million
students out of school in just the u.s.
pretty much close to a billion globally
and it happened so fast because of of
just the health emergency and I don't
think a lot have thought that was was no
one had time to think about what the
implications but now is becoming clear
that in most of the world the school
closures actually might happen through
the summer and so the way we've been
thinking about it is we want to be able
to support teachers parents students
over the next two months so that we can
keep the learning happening keep
everyone learning but we also see summer
is a really powerful opportunity to keep
going there's no reason that once you've
built the practices and the habits to
keep learning over what would be the
traditional school year that whether
you're a student parent or teacher that
you can't go over those three months as
well and that might be the the silver
lining of historically summer has been
you know there's the term Summer Slide
it's been a time for a lost learning and
now we have an opportunity to do now we
have an opportunity to make it valuable
for for learning purposes and so yes
simple answer the what we're trying to
do in response to the school closures in
kovat we expect to be able to do through
the summer and I think next school year
is going to
interesting we all hope that the social
distancing the school closures are not
in place as of back to school hopefully
the summer temperatures will help kill
some of that virus reduce the spread but
there is a possibility that in October
November December what's traditionally
flu season could actually make Kovac go
up again and so we also want to think
about if if that happens how we can
continue to support folks but the big
big takeaway is summer is an opportunity
that we all have to keep everyone
learning excellent question all right so
there's another question this is from
Facebook Deena Evert niveau says hi I'm
a parent nuta Khan I saw the sample
daily agendas how do I link the daily
schedule to my children's accounts
thanks well Deena that the schedules are
very simple documents and you can
actually adapt them you can copy and
paste them into your own Docs and and
adapt them as necessary and those just
have links to the relevant part of Khan
Academy and what if the student if your
if your child clicks on the link it will
go to their Khan Academy and if they're
logged in they will show up as a logged
in users so if they click from their
from their computers or whatever they're
using if they click on that you know -
let's call it 5th grade English and
language arts on that document they'll
go to Khan Academy and see 5th grade
language arts and if they're not logged
in they can log in and they'll be logged
into 5th grade language arts if they're
already logged in on that computer they
will they will be on their accounts so I
think that's what you might be asking
and that brings up another interesting
thing is you know we've made those
schedules we made 4 different versions
of them one for kind of the pre-k
kindergarten first grade crowd one for
the elementary crowd and then one for
the middle school and one for the late
high school crowd and what you could do
is then make them even more fine-tuned
for your children's needs because for
example for the late elementary crowd we
said ok you might want to use third
grade or fourth grade or fifth grade or
sixth grade or seventh grade math on
Khan Academy and depending on the
strength of the student you might want
to remediate it or not but you know your
children better than anyone
they know themselves hopefully and so
you can narrow that down you know work
on sixth grade or if you had some weak
foundations work on fourth and fifth
grade while you work on sixth grade as
well so completely encourage you to
fine-tune those schedules for your
children's needs so Sal I would add next
week we are hosting some parent webinars
for different age groups specifically
and we'll be going through both your
schedule that you created and kind of
helping parents find the right content
for their kids and diving a little bit
deeper on how to use Khan Academy
specifically matching to those schedules
awesome so we have a question yeah we
have a great question on YouTube from
our Roth Jane who says I'm in fourth
grade I want to learn more about
Sciences can you post something on Khan
Academy about that
so our of we want to help you we
currently do not have what you could
call fourth grade science on Khan
Academy but we and I hope over time we
are able to add that and I'll remind
everyone we're not-for-profit the more
support we get the more we can think
about adding more subjects but if you
are genuinely interested in science I
think there are places you can start I
actually think that you could we have
several for example even our high school
biology and I know you're only I'm
guessing nine years old and high school
biology could seem daunting but I
actually think some of the intro levels
of high school biology you could start
to engage in my oldest son is about is
actually a little bit or the new my
daughter's about your age and actually
I've been doing stuff even in some of
the early chemistry high school
chemistry units on what's an element
what's an atom with an atomic number I
think these are types of things you
could completely understand and it'll be
really interesting especially some of
the stuff in biology to understand you
know I was talking to my daughter who's
about your age this morning about what's
a virus how's the fire is different than
bacteria are viruses living you know
what's the definition of life
what's RNA and DNA how do viruses
replicate so this is obviously very very
important things to think about that's
very relevant to the world right now and
I encourage you to depending on your
interest to start digging in and see
what what works for you see other
questions so this is from Facebook Scott
yang asks I enjoyed the daily live
streams will you do it again next week
yeah where we are set to keep doing this
until no one wants us to do no no we we
think this is super important and I say
at the end of every live stream I myself
in this time of social distancing feel
more connected by being able to do this
and I know a lot of our team here at
Khan Academy does so we want to do it
for Shore keep that connection going and
make sure that all of you feels
supported
so from YouTube Stephen almonds or says
when was Khan Academy founded and Steven
if you do a web search you'll find a lot
of you know talks on YouTube and other
places for for me talking about that so
if you want to death I recommend you
your doing that but long story short
about 1450 actually 16 years ago I'm
getting old
my cousin Nadia who was 12 at the time
needed help with math and I started
tutoring her remotely work out around my
family that free tutoring was going on
and so people and so I started making
resources to scale it up the its at
first I had nothing to do with videos I
was creating the software part the early
version of what you can now the practice
software in Khan Academy and then a
friend suggested that I make videos to
supplement it and that kind of took on a
life of its own and 2009 2008 I set up
as a not-for-profit which just means no
one owns Khan Academy I don't own Khan
Academy I'm an employee of Khan Academy
I own as much as you own of Khan Academy
and then 2009 was when I quit my day job
to try to work on this full-time it was
a tough year I was living off the
savings but then in 2010 we got some of
our first support from some foundations
and corporations and so we've been able
to grow all the way till today where
were over 200 folks we have thousands of
volunteers there's 40 translation
efforts around the world of Khan Academy
we're trying to add subjects and grades
and we were already reaching 17 18 19
million students a month before the
crisis and it looks like our daily users
is up roughly 50% now and our actual
total traffic is up 2.5 so it's been a
bit
a wild ride but we feel privileged to be
able to support you and so many other
folks then you got more questions yeah
so I just wanted to share here's our
10-year t-shirt from last year so
showing off is clothing I'm so sad we
have a question on YouTube from Carmen
Carmen ha
paste I'll have a question will you will
the schedule you made for all of us will
you switch it up or will it stay the
same that is a great question and it was
a Carmenita so that's the schedules you
see where the first pass that we put out
a little over a week ago
and I hope that as as we kind of get our
legs under us that we can provide more
and more supports for y'all one thing we
are very seriously talking about are yes
can we extend that schedule to maybe
think about what goals could be week by
week as we go through this crisis not
just over the course of the next couple
of months during the traditional school
year but to a previous question asker go
through the summer so that you know hey
given your grade level given what you're
trying to achieve what are reasonable
goals for you to achieve and it would be
cool to even switch it up like hey
here's the the PE of the day so what
we're trying to do it we have a small
but mighty team and we're gonna try to
put as much together as possible but
that's a really cool idea to think about
how could we switch it up day by day a
bit maybe we give a weekly schedule or
something like that so we're gonna work
on that let's see there's other
questions some Facebook Tamra Adams says
is this noon or is this a new normal of
distance learning how do you believe is
the best platform for assessments so
Tamra you know what you're asking is a
really intriguing question I I've been
writing actually just there was an op-ed
that came out today that I wrote about
you know people are a lot of people are
asking me what's the new normal what's
structurally how is this crisis going to
fundamentally alter what we do going
forward in schooling and obviously in a
bunch of other ways the way I've been
thinking about it is given that this is
you know we're likely to go through the
end of the school year and then summer
and then as we go into next school year
hopefully schools are open but then they
might have to close with fairly short
notice
if if the virus picks up again in
November December I think this is where
the hybrid of in-person learning and
having great online tools that are
accessible and free is starting to
become even more important even before
the crisis we've talked a lot about that
everyone learns at different paces ever
and has gaps in their knowledge if
they're pushed together at a fixed pace
teachers have always known this they
have students who come into a class on
day one there are some kids who are
ready to move ahead there's some kids
who have gaps from two three grade
levels behind teachers try to kind of
teach to the middle but that leaves some
kids a little bored some kids a little
lost and there was no way for them you
know they're taught in ed schools to try
to differentiate but it's really hard if
you're one teacher in a classroom of
2530 or in some cases 35 or 40 students
and so even before the crisis all of us
at Khan Academy have been working with
teachers and districts to say okay how
can we support teachers in that way so
they have the tools how can we be the
teaching assistant for that teacher so
they have the tools to give that
personalization for every student so
they can fill their gaps and if
necessary learn along the class if
necessary and even accelerate as
necessary and then how do we do it with
districts so that districts can have a
read on where their kids need help or
not and now all of a sudden when you
have these school closures the districts
that have adopted that those types of
models where they were using tools like
Khan Academy for even 20% of their class
time really is a strategic supplement
it's been much easier for them to
transition to the school closure world
because they can now lis you know
they've already rostered their kids and
set them up the students are used to
using these tools the teachers are used
to reading the dashboards and so they've
been able to lean quite heavily on these
you see the teacher or the district
version of Khan Academy and have a
seamless transition and so I think the
new one of the new normals is the
emphasis on being able to blend is going
to be really important blend so that you
can accelerate outcomes during a normal
school year but also blend so that if
whatever reason there's a school
stoppage that the kids can keep learning
and then the district and the teachers
can keep monitoring I think there's a
whole other layer that's going to be
really interesting around you know I've
been talking to some school districts
lately they're doing all sorts of
training to help teachers start teaching
on Google me or on zoom so I think
that's going to be a new muscle that
even when schools in session
I think might actually be an added
muscle that'll be really powerful for
for a lot of types of schooling so we
will see but a lot of things going on I
think one of the biggest questions that
everyone's thinking about is access
obviously if you're watching this you
have internet access at home but there's
still a large fraction of kids in the
u.s. and even a larger fraction globally
who don't and I think this crisis shows
us that at home internet access is not
just a nice-to-have it's a must-have not
just to access things like Khan Academy
and keep learning but also to just be
socially connected and for your mental
health when all of us are having to be
socially distanced great question though
and something we're thinking about it a
lot so Sal we have a question on
Facebook from Elizabeth Warner and this
is relevant for a lot of folks so where
can a parent find out more about the
upcoming parent webinars next week where
is the best place to find these
opportunities to send parents to and
really what's the best place to find all
of our resources that we're developing
right now I could answer if I want to
steel dance Thunder because he's
actually the guy yeah sure so if you
just go to Khan Academy org right now we
have a blue ribbon at the top and it
contains links to all of our resources
our parent webinars the ones that are
upcoming are listed there as well as
webinars that we've already performed
will you create links there and it
available for you to view so in case you
can't make any of them live there
they're available to you after the fact
as well yeah exactly you just go to our
homepage or actually any page on Khan
Academy that banner at the top there's
three or four links one of them is kind
of you know we've been posting stuff on
the daily schedules because a lot of
people have been looking at and also
that remote learning resources link that
you can see right now and we are we are
and Dan is one of the many people who is
constantly updating that to keep you
informed and also stay tuned on social
media our Facebook page our Twitter etc
that's also where we're gonna be making
announcements on new new resources that
we are adding alright so there's other
questions so a facebook from facebook
Mary Miller's asking any thoughts and
adding more arts courses to the
curriculum so we don't have any major
plans to add significantly new ones and
Dan Don if there's a little hum from
yours or maybe lowered the microphone
there I'm getting a hum it's not it's
not horrible oh yes much almost so
peaceful no but on the art courses we we
aren't going to add any new significant
ones but we have a partnership with Beth
and Steven who do smart history who've
been adding art history content on Khan
Academy for many many years now and so
if you haven't seen it already I do
encourage you to explore art history on
Khan Academy it's really really
interesting stuff where they're having
these cool conversations about some of
the most important pieces of art in the
world or actually almost all the
important pieces of art in the world
so I encourage you to check that out all
right so there's other questions here
from Facebook Kara actually let's see
there's other questions below the so
from YouTube Kimberly Klein asks what
advice do you have for GED students
using the website so Kimberly my
recommendation to you if as a GED stood
I think there's two things you could do
actually even though it's not built for
a GED I think our SAT practice could be
great for the GED it's it covers roughly
the same you know math reading and
writing and so if you get good at that
I'm confident that you will do just fine
on the GED if you feel like you have
some more foundational gaps especially
in math or reading then I encourage you
to try to find your learning edge on
Khan Academy math and the Khan Academy
English and language arts and you could
do that by just sampling and say okay
the algebra stuff seems a little hard
okay the seventh grade stuff feels a
little bit easy eighth grade feels right
for me and then I you could take the
course challenge and use that to assess
what you know and don't know and then
focus on the unit
that that that where you might have
larger gaps there's another way where
you could actually start at the earliest
possible stage at second grade in
English and language arts and second
grade in math or even earlier in math
you could start and just go from there
and if you feel like it's ridiculously
easy you can skip to the next grade but
that actually might be and you can take
the course challenges in math that might
be one of the most robust ways of making
sure that you don't have any
debilitating gaps what we've seen even
strong students a B student or in middle
school high school even in 3rd 3rd or
4th grade they you know they might have
mastery of 99% of it but there's always
that one's like oh that's what that's
why the distributive property works this
way or things like that things that
they've just you know taken for granted
but even that helps fill in a gap so I
think that's something that you can do
so from Facebook me Ron
rrahhh asks how can we make sure that we
maintain a good mental health during
these uncertain times you are my hero
well thank thank you mehran you're being
very generous the on the mental health
side of things you know and this is
something I think a lot about because
even before this crisis you know
sometimes life can get stressful jobs
can get stressful school can get
stressful what I have found invaluable
and y'all have seen me talk about this
before has been meditation and you know
meditation isn't some fancy new age
thing I mean it is a fancy new age thing
as well but it doesn't have to be a
fancy New Age thing you know meditation
it literally can be you know you can
start five minutes in the morning and
I've personally found the morning or
right before I go to bed but especially
the morning is about is the best when
the house is quiet is the best time to
meditate and it's literally just finding
a quiet space sitting you know posture
matters a lot sit upright close your
eyes be attentive and just try to
observe your thoughts and you'll realize
that you are not your thoughts that's
there's all this stuff that's going on
your thoughts oh I got to get that thing
done why did that person say that and
how am I going to do this and
you know what's going on on that TV show
that I'm watching and you know and yet
you like what's gonna happen with Cove
advice you know all these thoughts are
going in our head right now and what you
need to do is just learn to observe
those thoughts and separate yourself
from those thoughts and you know the a
metaphor and we've done some guided
meditations on kind of gay there you
have it Philippe it's a put the screen
so you can go use these guided
meditations if you want a little bit of
help but over time you'll be able to do
it on your own and you're gonna realize
that as you rise above the thoughts you
know if you view the thoughts as cars on
a highway you just kind of get out of
the highway and just watch the cars go
by that the car starts slowing down and
you're gonna have these moments where
you're like well you're not even
thinking about it you're just not
thinking and when you have even five
minutes of that a day and your mind will
wander and don't beat up for yourself
just say okay mind yeah that's funny you
wandered come on back in you're kind of
like a sheep herding dog for your mind
and your mind is are this the sheep so
you just kind of there's a little sheep
that's going astray and you got to bring
it back but I found if even five minutes
a day but over time you're going to like
it you're gonna want to do 10 minutes 15
minutes I do half an hour every morning
you're gonna have moments in that half
an hour where your mind is wandering but
moments in that half an hour where
you're just completely still and you'll
all feel really happy and really really
calm and I found that it's not just for
that 30 minutes or that 10 minutes that
you're meditating it just makes you more
mentally resilient through the day it's
you're it's it's harder for people to
trigger you so to speak you get less
worked up about things and you get less
stressed about things and so that's
that's my best advice and you know just
don't beat up on yourself take
everything one day at a time you know to
quote frozen one and frozen to frozen
one you know let it go and frozen to do
the next right thing which is awfully
deep philosophy which is actually
consistent with most of the mystical
traditions of most religions so
unfortunately with the crisis affecting
everyone around the world this questions
particularly important so from YouTube
online education Nepal says hello Sal
I'm Pushpa from Nepal how can you move
this into different languages great
question Pushpa so there are 40
translation projects of
Academy around the world and there are
different degrees of fidelity we have
the richest versions in Spanish speaking
Latin America Brazilian Portuguese and
we've we have actually a team in India
that is trying to work on the various
languages in India and aligned to the
standards in all of these places and
then of course you have this other 30
something projects going on so that's
what's going on right now I'm actually
not expert on the state of Nepalese if
that's a particular interest but if we
don't already have a translation project
there obviously we would love people to
start one so that's one layer that we
that we think we can help with and then
the other layer is in many parts of the
world things like internet access etc
and you know there were we are trying we
do try to work with philanthropist
corporations telecom carriers to make it
more accessible but but that's our best
answer right now alright YouTube Tom Yum
Hyundai is asking a really simple
question what do you think is the
purpose of life that's a good question
yeah I mean you know I think I think not
to get too metaphysical or too deep we
find ourselves in this big mystery and I
think you know current world events you
know which feel almost surreal dystopian
whatever you want to call it I think
really emphasize because it that we're
font we're finding ourselves in this big
mystery and I think one of the purposes
is to reflect on the mystery and to
experience this this mystery that we
call life in the universe and everything
in them I would see I'm making a few
references to Douglas Adams but but yeah
I you know I can't claim that I know the
purpose of life I will say that
sometimes in your moments when you can
actually steal your thoughts and bring
your mind away from I guess you could
call it material reality and all of the
distractions in material reality
sometimes you you can feel a deep peace
and connectedness to the universe
whatever you might want to call that and
I think that actually can sometimes make
you feel very grounded and very
very happy and so you know I can't
necessary describe that it's a purpose
of life but it can give you maybe a lens
on life but it's it's a it's a it's a
really really good question one met of
one framework you know who knows if this
is true is you know this is this is
something of a learning experience for
you know obviously we talk about
learning at the academic level but life
itself is a mega learning experience and
you know there's there's there's
frameworks of imagining that every
person on the planet is another version
of yourself and so you are you know
we're all connected in some way who
knows I don't want to get to a
metaphysical because I don't know the
answers but it's a it's a deep question
that I'm sure we will keep keep keep
struggling with okay so I'm YouTube's
Gurpreet is asking how to deal with
demotivation and how to approach a new
topic I think the number thing another
one thing with D motivation or
procrastination is to just get started
and I've talked about it in other
sessions there's something called the
Pomodoro Technique
where you can kind of set a timer say
I'm gonna do 20 minutes and I'm gonna
focus and I'm gonna get something done
and then and then give yourself a break
after that force a break after that and
then jump back in and you know one thing
that I've always reminded myself is to
just keep on moving I actually I'm a big
believer in starting the day with making
your bed and I have a little bit of a
ritual which includes meditation I go do
some pull-ups in my garage I do some I
do some push-ups and and the reason why
I do those things it's not so much even
for my health or or to make my my bed
look nice it gives me some winds early
in the day and I find that on days and
I'm able to have some accomplishments
within twenty thirty minutes of waking
up that my brain just loves that feeling
and wants to then have more our
accomplishments and and and check more
things off so that's my my best advice
and when I approach a new topic I view
it as an adventure you know and so some
is just you could approach life in this
it's like a mystery it's like a game and
it's a puzzle and so even if something
looks dry or you're not sure how it
applies to your life at first if you
look at it with that lens and if you
look at it through the lens that you're
able to look at human knowledge that has
been a cue
over thousands of years and you are the
beneficiary of being able to consume
that you know Isaac Newton would have
would have done anything to have access
to the textbooks the resources that we
have today
Pythagoras would have done anything
Marie Curie would have done anything to
have access to a modern chemistry or
biology book we get that and and we get
the lifetime's work of so many people
who dedicate their lives to it so you it
that way it's quite exciting I think to
learn and it's fun to meditate in a
different way or it's fun to sit and and
and think about the learning in a way
that it forms those neural connections
in your brain and it becomes intuitive
and when you do that in one subject all
of a sudden a lot of other things start
to make a lot of sense so it looks like
we're all out of time you guys got me
talking about topics that have limited
knowledge about but I enjoy pondering
but I just want to remind everyone or I
tell everyone thank you for for joining
we do this every week day at noon
pacific 3:00 p.m. Eastern it's a fun way
for all of us to connect at this time of
social distancing and we want to do
everything in our power to keep students
teachers parents learning keep them
supported and I'll also put another plug
in we are not-for-profit please donate
if you are if you're in the position to
do so thank you so much
you